this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon
hey crazies we've been doing a lot with
space-time diagrams lately figuring out
how different observers measure the
passage of time but that got several of
you asking does that mean the future is
predetermined and we don't have free
will well maybe maybe not deep questions
like this require careful scrutiny all
we know for sure from diagrams like this
is that time exists that doesn't
necessarily mean that the future or even
the past exists hmm
maybe we should define these words first
the past is the time or period of time
before the present the future is the
time or period of time following the
present so both of these are defined in
terms of the current moment if it kind
of makes sense that the present the now
is what we're experiencing but it feels
like the past exists we remember the
past happening well none of us remember
that or or that but I certainly remember
all of these moments whether I want to
or not but does that exist or is that
just a memory we're experiencing now the
future also feels like it's going to
happen even if we don't know what it'll
be does that exist or is that just a
prediction we're making now hmm let's
see what this looks like on a spacetime
diagram you are here this event
represents your present you're now
whether you're stationary moving in a
steady speed constantly accelerating or
doing something completely random you
can't go any faster than light light
travels along these diagonal paths so
your path is stuck inside those lines
this half happened before your present
it's your past all the events that might
have influenced you this half will
happen after your present it's your
future all the events you might
influence your entire life is contained
inside these regions no matter what you
might have done or what you might decide
to do those two regions are called your
past and future light coats cones
how are those cones oh right right right
let me
slang only having a single space axis
makes these look like triangles but if
you include a second space axis you can
see they're really cones
you just have to consider light
traveling at any direction actually
there are three phases yeah yeah but our
axis limit is three it and one of them
has to be time but besides most motion
happens in two dimensions anyway let's
not overcomplicate this anyway this
still leaves a few things open I said
might a lot during that space-time
diagram so are we predetermined to
travel our space-time paths or not this
comes down to an idea called causality
or cause and effect and relativity
number six says it must be maintained no
matter what that means if one event
causes another then everyone agrees they
happen in that order cause before effect
let's say you are the cause and you want
to affect me at a particular time I must
be somewhere in your future light color
maybe I'm directly on the path you're
taking so you'll be able to touch me
maybe I'm not on your path but I'm close
enough to throw a rock at maybe I'm so
far away from you the only way you can
affect me is with light in all cases
from all points of view the cause comes
before the effect so is all of time just
a string of cause and effect not so fast
if an event happens outside your
influence then the distinction between
past and future kind of melts away say
there's an event outside your future
light cone outside your influence you
might still think it happens in the
future because on your timeline it
happens at a later time but someone else
might say it happened in the past
because on their timeline it happened at
an earlier time wait wait something can
happen in one person's future but
another person's past yep so the future
and the past are very personal concepts
they belong to the observer but the
observer is only in the present which
reminds me of something there's one
property of the universe we haven't
considered locality or a local idiy
we've discussed this in previous videos
but it could bear some repeating whether
we're talking basic mechanics Allah
magnetism space-time curvature or even
quantum fields the universe is
inherently local the idea is that a
physical thing can only be influenced by
its immediate surroundings
in other words in order for a thing over
there to affect me here it has to either
come here or send something here which
brings us to another relevant question
how big is here it's really really small
local for a person might look like this
it's pretty small for me okay I have to
admit this is a little uncomfortable
anyway this is my space my here and it
works for anything the size of me if
that local box is too small like it
would be for my space station then it's
it's a little overkill but it's fine if
it's way too big like it would be for
particles then it simply won't work so
smaller is better ideally it would have
exactly zero size but that poses a few
problems
the main problem being that we can't
divide by zero it just doesn't work
luckily we've got a trick that gets us
around this problem let's start with two
points separated by this much space say
this point is at five and this point is
at six or five plus one because they're
separated by one unit
maybe it's inches maybe it's centimeters
whatever it doesn't matter if we make
this space a little smaller
the second point might be at five plus a
half or five plus 1/10 or five plus a
hundredth or five plus a thousandth the
points keep getting closer together
they're almost the same point but not
quite if we keep this up we can get
closer and closer and closer until the
points are at five and five plus an
unimaginably tiny number so tiny it's
not even useful to label it as a number
anymore we call it an infinitesimal and
label it DX welcome to calculus I know
my calculus you post me equals us anyway
in infinitesimal as an amount of space
that is as close to zero as we can get
without actually being zero it's as
local as our math can get of course DX
is just one dimension
DX and dy make two dimensions included
DZ and you've got three dimensions also
known as space included DT and you've
got a four dimensional space times the
volume DX dy DZ is the local here and
the DT is the local now that's all that
really exists
there's no universal reference frame
because there's no universe at least in
the way that people usually understand
it this space-time diagram is only a
mapped of predictions about a
non-existent future and predictions
about a non-existent past it's attached
to you as you move through space-time
space-time doesn't deny you free will
because the future doesn't exist all
that exists for anyone is their local
here and their local now you might not
have control over much in your life but
you always have a choice about what kind
of person you are here and now make that
choice a good one
please share your thoughts in the
comments thanks for liking and sharing
this video don't forget to subscribe if
you'd like to keep up with us and until
next time remember it's okay to be a
little crazy why is the speed of light
that specific number well we know it
can't go at infinite speed because that
would violate causality it has to be
finite but the exact value is kind of an
accident as far as we can tell it could
just as easily be a different value in a
different universe the universe just
might not have humans in it anyway
thanks for watching that's fast